ciao ragazzi e ciao ragazze
io sono Maryna e sono una youtuber italiana
e questo é il mio primo video in spagnolo
questo é il primo episodio del mio nuovo format video
che si chiama : " Una Youtuber in Cucina"
quello che preparerò oggi é uno dei miei piatti preferiti
é un piatto che adoro e che cucino tutte le domeniche per i miei amici
sto parlando dei pancakes americani
oltre ai classici pancakes dolci
oggi voglio proporvi anche i pancakes in versione salata
gli ingredienti che ci servono sono :
125 ml di latte
100 gr di farina
un uovo
30 gr di burro
un cucchiaino di sale
e lievito (non vanigliato)
una casseruola, uno sbattitore elettrico e ... iniziamo subito!
per prima cosa separiamo il tuorlo dall'albume
in seguito montiamo l'albume con lo sbattitore
facciamo sciogliere il burro in un pentolino facendo attenzione a non bruciarlo
aggiungiamo al tuorlo, il burro fuso
il latte
la farina
il cucchiaino di sale
e il cucchiaino di lievito
mescoliamo il tutto fino ad ottenere un impasto liscio ed omogeneo
al quale andremo ad aggiungere l'albume precedentemente montato
ora facciamo scaldare la padella
e versiamo delicatamente una piccola quantità di composto con un mestolo
quando vediamo apparire delle piccole bolle in superficie
giriamo il pancake
e li lasciamo dorare da entrambi i lati
solo a quel punto i nostri pancakes saranno  pronti per essere farciti
potete farcirli come preferite
ma io vi consiglio la mia farcitura preferita
che é salmone affumicato con formaggio spalmabile all'erba cipollina
quindi spalmiamo il nostro formaggio e ci adagiamo sopra due belle fette di salmone affumicato
ed ecco qui
i pancakes salati di Maryna sono pronti
e adesso continuiamo con la ricetta dei classici pancakes americani dolci
gli ingredienti che ci servono sono :
due uova
80 gr di zucchero
200 gr di farina
200 ml di latte
due cucchiaini di lievito vanigliato
frutti di bosco
e sciroppo d'acero
iniziamo versando in una casseruola lo zucchero
aggiungiamo le uova
e mescoliamo fino ad ottenere un composto liscio ed omogeneo
adesso aggiungiamo la farina
e due cucchiaini di lievito vanigliato
mescoliamo bene
e aggiungiamo poco a poco il latte
l'impasto é pronto!
con un mestolo versiamo nella padella bella calda una piccola quantità d'impasto
e aspettiamo fino a quando appaiono le bolle in superficie
quindi li giriamo affinché si dorino da entrambi i lati
a me piace metterli uno sopra l'altro in modo da formare una piccola torre
quindi gli verso sopra un'abbondante quantità di sciroppo d'acero
e gli do una bella spolverata di zucchero a velo
possiamo guarnire il piatto con frutti di bosco
se volete preparare una porzione singola
bastano due pancakes, i frutti di bosco
la panna montata e ecco qua i miei fantastici pancakes dolci!
bene ragazzi, siamo giunti alla fine del video
spero che vi sia piaciuto
e spero che potrete gustare
questi pancakes insieme ai vostri amici
se non lo avete ancora fatto vi chiedo di iscrivervi al mio canale
di mettermi un bel like e seguirmi anche sugli altri miei social
un bacione a tutti voi
grazie per aver visto il mio primo video in spagnolo
e spero che non sia l'ultimo